with this news of this Democratic
senator asking the FTC to investigate
someone it's been seven days since FTX
went bankrupt seven days obviously
criminal fraud here obviously people
have been defrauded people have been
robbed of their money no one got
arrested Madoff got arrested in 24 hours
after his Ponzi scheme was was exposed
to everyone seven days later and then we
have the FBI warning the guy that
they're going to meet maybe maybe
possibly be going after him are you
kidding me this reeks of corruption and
this could be one of the reasons why
Elon Musk is like oh crap the FTC might
be on my butt I gotta do what they want
me to do as the federal government is
telling big Tech social media platforms
to ban particular voices again the US
government is violating the first
amendment in more ways than one
particularly when it comes to online
speech this could be one of the reasons
why we don't have free speech and we
won't have free speech on Twitter as
announced by Elon Musk today